eu quero começar esse tópico fazer duas
perguntas que ainda que já ouviu falar
pittoni e que ainda que já usou ou usa o
já teve quem sabe exatamente esperava
essa reação boa
eu ouvi falar bill clinton a primeira
vez há uns quatro anos aqui o técnico
numa fala de tudo quando elas postaram
história e estava falar comigo e fiquei
convencido que estava em um esquema que
tudo termine numa alhada qual ele fica
lá é porque é um conceito muito
esquecido é um negócio que não precisa
de uma entidade central para funcionar
um dinheiro que não precisa de time
uma coisa que faz com função importante
foi lançado numa jornada que não foi só
aquela tarefa que eu passei a pesquisar
na internet aprovará um nome que eu
estava errado
essa taxa fosse uma semana essa semana
transformou se num mês e esse mesmo
risco transformou se de uma opção de
quatro anos que eu vou mostrar hoje
porque é que o porquê dessa opção
e ela começa quando quando eu percebi
que é uma quarta função da forma como
temos 100 no início não existia troca
direta as coisas funcionavam troca
direta e passaram a funcionar por fração
do valor do ser humano com insulza
conchas pedras o que quer que seja
representado por uma atração por
passarmos para metais preciosos e dos
metais preciosos para utilizar um moedas
e notas nas moedas e notas e o diário de
hoje tem uma peculiaridade que a unidade
mais de 90% dos dólares e euros que
estão em circulação são digitais são
eletrônicos não são representados de
forma nenhuma por uma moeda uma nota
nada são bits que vai da nossa direção
pensa então mas se eu conseguir virar
pizza e vai pro outro lado do continente
sempre deu autorização a ninguém sem ter
que te acompanhar comissões sem ter
permissão de um banho ajuda companhia
por que não posso fazer isso com uma
mulher se o dinheiro também é digital
porque não posso enviar os bits e bytes
já representa o meu dinheiro
por outro lado do mundo a infecção sem o
chate a resposta é que eu posso fazer
isso é esporte não é um não vai em 2008
us 16 entidades que ninguém sabe quem é
o seu aniversário com a china a moda
apresentar um pai para o título bitcoin
pirtuc electrónicas tem um sistema
eletrônico que é pior do que não querem
a presença de membros da central se o
envio deve ter alguém olhar vai
directamente impeça pessoa não preciso
entender a área
enquanto isto o utilizador
isso não é muito diferente tudo é que
nós conhecemos hoje portanto vocês estão
vendo aqui é uma aplicação do telemóvel
chamado uma carteira de cliente consegue
encarar de frente que estamos habituados
mas não é muito diferente usava uma
carteira bem piores do que usar o paypal
por exemplo temos 16 receber uma forma
que enfiar e com o cliente e minério do
outro o um lado do mundo world de
tecnologia turbo boost disse que a
evolução acontece
e essa tecnologia se chama tecnologia
bluemotion que permite total de
centralização de centralização accor de
uma malha aérea e tecnicamente difícil
de explicar
eu acho que a maneira mais fácil de
explicar é contada a história de uma
transação como é que a transação
acontece à tarde começa com um clique do
aviário e essa transação enviada
espalhada por toda a internet por cerca
de 5 mil computadores estão com este
software em segundo e em segundo esta
transação é consiga por todo mundo
há alguns destes nós são os nossos
especiais chamados os minérios e cimed
tem o objetivo de equilibrar as
transações box transações conjunto de
transacções lançar uma prova matemática
para fingir que essas transações são
viáveis são proprietários não são
são transações na opinião de tite mesmo
transações já feitas por exemplo se eu
criar uma vitória
e enviar a mesma para duas pessoas este
transação não pode estar a querer
trabalhos finais e em segundo 4 o
networking e agora temos um caso prático
porque toda a tecnologia precisa de uma
colecção não houvesse uma aplicação
prática isso não fazia sentido e é o
caso de um trabalhador migrante essa
história acontece todos os meses e há
muita gente a votar esta tecnologia
nestes neste contato
imaginemos um trabalhador mexicano vai
para os estados unidos para trabalhar
enviar de volta pra cima porque ele
achava que essa história acontece em
eventos ea imensa pessoas nessa situação
chega ao fim do mês do trabalhador
precisa efetivamente enviaram geral é
refratário que acontece no sistema
bancário tradicional do álbum dizem que
em média esse trabalhador de gastar 800
do valor que enviam entrada em taxas de
internações além fronteiras
pensar que um trabalhador com média de
50 horas semanais
parece um valor relativamente positiva a
este triste trabalhador está a trabalhar
quatro horas semanais para uma entidade
que nada mais faz do que enviar parte de
um lado para o outro do mundo
uma tira que o que ia fazer por mim sem
curar os três a cinco dias úteis que
washington espera concluí o convite põe
o que acontece é esse dinheiro não há
fronteiras e concluí o dinheiro chega à
família do trabalhador novembro na vida
é um mar de rosas e há casos e casos
essa tecnologia pode ser usada provar e
aprovar um qualquer tecnologia vocês vão
ver a vossa direto é um símbolo de uma
plataforma construída num canto obscuro
na internet
desta forma a chance eu trouxe
chamava-se o bronze em dubai mas vamos
ver se venderem álbuns e as coisas que
nem vai desde as trocas armas comprime
di tá tudo que você possa imaginar eles
neste sítio farias também pensar um
período sem títulos em dinheiro que não
há fronteiras não tem um controle
central é uma coisa que fez pensar
durante algum tempo
pressionada e pensar nem precisa
escolher outras tecnologias pensar como
é que as outras tecnologias foram
aprovaram neste nosso time de moral e
essa tecnologia tecnologia que olha que
eu usar para comprar foi internet porque
não é um mosteiro com o melhor eo pior o
meia também surgiu no fim da década de
60 e no início da década de 70 já tinha
sido aqui
agora eu pergunto será que fazia sentido
proibir a internet nesta altura é faltou
interesse ativamente pequena era
possível proibir internet
será que porque a aplicações mais a
internet faz com que true vila como um
todo
obviamente ficou em apenas um protocolo
e pode ser usado prova e para o mal tem
tecnologia é moralmente neutra
o que importa é o que fazemos com ela e
isso deve ser lavado e chegar à parte
que eu fico satisfeito porque meu
palpite no início de quatro vai estar
certo de que o parto onde fica o
escritório está hoje estavam esta
tecnologia desta moeda virtual tem neste
momento uma capitalização no mercado 20
cerca de 20 mil milhões de dólares cerca
de 300 milhões de dólares mas sim não
não mãos a cada 24 horas sobre esta
tecnologia
há cada vez mais empresas a aceitar esta
moeda em troca o bicho vai ser visto por
exemplo a loja online da microsoft site
há uma grande loja norte-americana que
sai da loja online ou as físicas
essa tecnologia está em todo o lado e
pretende fazer pela inter pela internet
único hoje em dia toda a gente tem
direito a uma opinião
amanhã quando o equipamento for adotada
é toda a gente tem direito a serviços
bancários básicos e eu sei que estas são
as perguntas que a nossa cabeça hoje as
perguntas que estava de cabeça ela
estavam feitas num papo encontrar do
início da pesquisa e da europa por
responder a todas elas são
como é que os vídeos onde são criadas
final para quem é canhoto é que há
alguém está enganado e também aqui o
tubo estava a responder ele tentava
responder e falou para impor sobre o
teclado favor no âmbito com outras ongs
muito estranho professor que introduzirá
isso gostava de dizer se era digital
porque não pode simplesmente fazer
campeões e enviar a mesma coisa por duas
pessoas é um espetáculo estava dizer se
eu tenho uma aplicação do telemóvel tem
duas pítons e o primeiro telemóvel que
acontece é que faz sentido ter um
serviço bancário assim tão frágil
gostava de falar com o substituto mas
não perdeu e portanto teria todo o gosto
em falar com o coxa é seguir a próxima
apresentação
obrigado
[Aplausos]